[Musique]
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur Alexandre Orlof
bonjour bonjour nous vous recevons au
nom du club des vigilants et de la
chaîne Youtube Serview on aurait aimé
avoir un petit peu votre raisonnement
sur les récentes actualités qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire un petit peu
votre point de vue sur la géopolitique à
l'heure
actuelle bah écoutez il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire puisque l'actualité elle
est très très riche l'actualité
internationale l'actualité intérieure
française que je veux pas commenter vous
me
contendrez mais on est un peu à la fin
de l'année et je crois que si on euh
jette un regard vers l'arrière c'est on
compare le début de l'année avec la fin
je dirais que à mon
avis la perception de la Russie Estelle
évolue elle évolue elle évolue dans le
monde elle évolue en France et pour moi
c'est la chose sans doute la plus
importante en tant que l'ambassadeur de
ce
pays je vois
que il y a de plus en plus des pays qui
se tournent vers la Russie comme un pays
allié dans la lutte commune contre le
défi le plus important que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est sans doute le défi de
du terrorisme et là la France joue un
rôle extrêmement important alors je peux
aussi dire que les les événements autour
de la Syrie ont montré que finalement il
y
a pas beaucoup de pays dans le monde qui
ont une responsabilité globale et qui
sont capables de jouer un vrai jeu
géopolitique alors vous avez vu que on a
lancé à cette automne le processus de
Vienne qui est un processus d'accomag
d'accompagnement du du règlement
politique en série et là alors ce
processus a été lancé avant tout par la
Russie les États-Unis d'Amérique la
France a sans doute a joué aussi son
rôle mais en même temps on a vu que dans
le jeu géopolitique par exemple le rôle
de l'Allemagne est très diminué autant
l'Allemagne
reste un partenaire incontournable un
pays majeur au sein de l'Union
européenne rien ne peut se faire en
l'ion européenne sans l'Allemagne autant
dans le monde comme il y a 30 ans il y a
finalement que euh des membres
permanents du Conseil de sécurité avant
tout le la Russie l'Amérique et la
France qui continue à jouer ce jeu et
alors je constate aussi que il a eu un
rapprochement au niveau de deux
présidents d'ailleurs je j'assiste à
toute leur rencontre dès le début dès
l'élection de François Hollande comm
président de la République française je
dois dire qu'ils ont eu toujours contre
ement ce que disent certains
journalistes des bons rapports
personnels mais je constate que dans les
circonstances actuelles ces rapports se
sont beaucoup amélioré qu' est vraiment
une vraie relation humaine un vrai
respect mutuel et ça facilite beaucoup
la recherche des solutions des problèmes
avant tout autour de la Syrie mais aussi
autour de
l'Ukraine bon alors je vais pas dire
peut-être davantage et je vais vous
donner la possibilité de me poser des
questions je vais me développer en
répondant à vos questions ça sera plus
intéressant pour vous et pour moi B
pendant qu'on envoie le micro dans la
salle je vais vous poser la première
question
euh nous avons fait une alliance contre
daesh et à côté on continue d'imposer
des sanctions à la
Russie bah écoutez c'est une
incohérence de la politique
extérieure euh de la France mais surtout
de de l'Union européenne puisque nous
savons très bien que aussi bien la
France que l'Allemagne sont favorbl à la
levée de ces sanctions qui étaient euh
complètement
illégitimes mais euh la vie au sein de
l'Union européenne est faite de façon
que la France et l'Allemagne ne peuvent
pas décider toute seule qu'il y a le
consensus à rechercher et là je crois
que je l'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois
que c'était une peut-être
erreur était commise dans la
construction européenne que les pays ont
déléguer une très grande partie de leur
souveraineté nationale à Bruxelles aux
fonctionnaires de Bruxelles et
maintenant il se trouve que sur des
questions très importantes comme par
exemple les relations avec la Russie ces
pays sont liés par les pays qui sont
beaucoup plus petits qui ont d' intérêt
que la France et l'Allemagne c'est un
problème institutionnel européenne qu'il
faut un jour sans doute résoudre d'une
façon ou d'une autre mais je crois je
crois que finalement
euh la situation générale évolue vers
l'assouplissement et la levée des
sanctions qui d'ailleurs n'ont pas été
euh très efficaces même pas du tout
efficace alors il a eu la volonté de la
part des avant tout des États-Unis sans
doute mais aussi de leurs alliés en
Europe d'isoler la Russie parce que
c'était
ça dans les sanctions qu'est-ce qu'on a
cherché deux choses la première
affaiblir la Russie économiquement et
deuxièmement isolé sur le plan
international VO isolé sur le plan
international on voit un échec total
puisque aujourd'hui au contrairement la
Russie est au centre du jeu géopolitique
sur le plan économique certes la Russie
a eu quelques difficultés mais ces
difficultés étaient plutôt passagère on
voit que l'économie comment continue à
se développer souffre plus de la baisse
du prix de pétrole que des sanctions
mais en même temps ceci a accéléré notre
politique de diversification de notre
économie on a été trop dépendant de
l'exportation des
hydrocarbures maintenant on on va
développer davantage notre industrie
mais surtout l'agriculture parce que moi
je pense que l'avenir de la Russie n'est
pas uniquement industriel mais aussi
agricole on parle aujourd'hui beaucoup
de climat la COP 21 c'est une actualité
on parle du climat de réchauffement mais
les choses qui est encore plus plus
important plus quotidien c'est la
nourriture les gens auront toujours
besoin à manger quelque chose ne
serait-ce que quelques croissant et là
la Russie est bien Leti la potentialité
de la Russie sur le plan de
l'agriculture de l'eau potable et
colossal colossal alors on a on a
investi dans dans l'agriculture dans
dans l'industrie ce que permettra à la
Russie de sortir de cette phase de la
politique internationale plus forte
qu'elle était avant je voudrais être
juste sûr qu'on vous a bien compris vous
affirmez que la France et l'Allemagne
sont prêtes à lever les sanctions dans
l'état actuel de la situation sans
nouvelle avancé sur le dossier de
l'Ukraine écoutez je suis pas président
de la France je peux pas affirmer que la
France est prête moi je dis ce que
j'entends et je sais que la France et
l'Allemagne sont favorables sont
favorables à la levée progressive des
sanctions sans doute sans doute vu
l'évolution sur le terrain vu
l'évolution avec l'application des
accords de Minsk mais nous voyons en
même temps que la France et l'Allemagne
s'emploie beaucoup pour que ces accord
soit accompli autant que la Russie
c'estàd il y a vraiment un intérêt
réciproque de la Russie de la France de
l'Allemagne que ces accords soient enfin
accomplis et qu'on puisse passer à la
levée des sanctions voilà ce que je
voulais dire juste sur ce point Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur par de et un micro j'arve
ouis j'entends bien
oui merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous
parlez du parallélisme dans le processus
de leve des sanctions et de
l'application des accords de Minsk sur
ce deuxième point quel est votre
sentiment sur la capacité et les délais
dans lesquels cet accord pour être
misise en œuvre notamment sur les
élections en Ukraine et le deuxème point
je rebondis sur votre question sur sur
l'Union européenne est-ce que vous
pensez que la nouvelle donne en Pologne
peut compliquer le
processus bon alors quand je parlais du
parallélisme entre la levée de sanctions
et l'application des accords de Minsk
c'est pas c'est pas nous qui on fait ce
parallélisme c'est un parallélisme qui
est fait par nos partenaires par nos
amis européens puisque encore une fois
je rappelle que ces sanctions étaient
une affaire unilatérale de la part de
l'Union européenne alors c'est l'Union
européenne qui a introduit ces sanctions
c'est l'union qui doit les lever à
quelles conditions on va pas le négocier
mais nous ce que nous faisons et là
c'est pas du tout pour lever des
sanctions mais pour intérêt général
c'est de résoudre enfin le problème de
l'Ukraine et là je crois que il y a deux
choses la première sur le plan de la
sécurité on assiste euh depuis le 1er
septembre de cette année
à une trêve à une trêve qui reste une
trêve fragile précaire mais néanmoins il
y a une trêve on se tue moin et alors
c'est un avancé considérable il faut
maintenant aller de l'avant avec le
processus politique et là il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes de la
part des Ukrainiens malheureusement qui
veulent pas parler avec les soi-disant
séparatistes il y a les accords de MSK
c'est une vraiment c'est une feuille de
route tout est inscrit dedans les points
1 2 jusque je crois 12 ou 13 tout est
tout est mis sur le papier il faut
accomplir et là les Ukrainiens trichent
et au lieu de passer un accord sur le
sur les élections locales préparant cet
accord cette loi avec les séparatistes
le font eux seul et après ils veulent
imposer il y a toujours cette volonté du
rejet hélas de de cette partie de
l'Ukraine qui complique énormément le
jeu et là je je peux vous dire que ceci
est très bien perçu par nos amis
français et les amis allemands qui
essaient de convaincre les Ukrainiens de
jouer le jeu de d'accomplir les accords
de Minsk nous de notre côté sans doute
nous travaillons avec avec les gens qui
représente l'est de l'ouraine mais
euh d'après d'après les les estimation
de de plusieurs experts nous pensons que
les 6 6 mois à venir seront les mois
décisifs c'est-à-dire on doit on doit
tenir d'abord adopter cette loi adopter
la loi sur l'amnestie générale et puis
tenir ces élections dans la la la
première moitié de l'année prochaine ce
qui sera une avancée décisive pour
appliquer les accords de Minsk et ceci
doit ouvrir la voie pour pour
l'évolution c'est-à-dire lever des
sanctions et et d'autres choses voilà
les choses que T que nous les ressentons
et T que je crois le ressentent nos amis
français allemands
oui Monsieur l'Ambassadeur Jean
torgemann président du club des
ambassadeurs
euh nous aimerions que vous puissiez
nous expliciter la position de la Russie
vis-à-vis de l'islamisme radical d'un
côté vous avez souffert d'attentat
terroristes dont tout le monde se
souvient de l'autre depuis le début de
la République islamique d'Iran qui a été
à l'origine de ces mouvements de
radicalisation de l'islam vous êtes
quand même un soutien et enfin
maintenant nous voyons l'évolution
vis-à-vis de la Turquie d'Erdogan qui se
révèle de plus en plus dans la mouvance
des Frères musulmans alors comment
comment tout ceci se situe et vu depuis
Moscou très bon question alors je veux
partir pour une demi-heure au
moins pour répondre à cette question bah
écoutez il y a plusieurs choses la
première il faut bien savoir que la
Russie c'est un pays
multiconfessionnel et par nombre
d'hébitants les musulmans c'est la deè
communauté de la Russie ça a été depuis
depuis le terrible c'estàd
depuis 15e siècle alors pendant ces 500
ans les musulmans les Slaves se sont
mélangés ils ont toujours vécu dans une
harmonie sans
problème
hélas l'islam c'est une religion tout à
fait respectable comme toute autre
religion mais dans toutes religions il y
a des
extrémistes et moi je pense que ceux
qu'il faut combattre ce sont pas des
religions mais des extrémistes quels
qu'il soi chrétiens
euh chrétiens ou musulmans toutes sortes
d'extrémismes c'est ça qui représente le
danger et alors euh nous nous sommes
confrontés avec cet islam radical 10 ans
avant vous hélas euh je pense que si
vous avez observer la vie de mon pays
vous vous vous souvenez il y a eu des
attentats très très meurtriés à Moscou
dans un théâtre à Moscou ça me rappelle
beaucoup Bataclan c'est vraiment c'est
déjà vu pour nous il a eu aussi une
attaque contre une école à besesselan le
1er septembre quand quand des dizaines
dizaines des enfants sont morts c'était
vraiment terrible terrible alors là on a
connu et puis elle a eu cette guerre de
T et on a éit beaucoup critiqué
maintenant on voit que c'est absolument
la même chose qui se passe aujourd'hui
en Syrie c'était la guerre non pas
contre le peuple Tchen mais contre ces
extrémistes qui se battaient d'ailleurs
aussi à l'époque on le disait que ces
extrémistes pour la plupart étaient des
étrangers c'était pas des tchiens
c'était des gens qui sont venus
justement des des pays où il y a
aujourd'hui l'État islamique alors pour
nous c'est un c'est un ennemi c'est un
ennemi commun qu'il faut
combattre après les attentats à Paris
bon j'ai reçu une délégation des imams
de France il sont venus me voir sur leur
propre
initiative j'ai eu une très belle
conversation trop bon conversation son
des gens tout à fait honorables et
respectables qu'ils m'ont dit des choses
que je que je savais déjà ils disait que
au lieu de fermer les mosquées il faut
chasser les mauvais imames ce sont pas
les mosquées ce sont pas des murs qui
prêchent ce sont des imams et là je
crois que nous sont confrontés au même
problème que vous je sais qu'en Russie
dans les régions où il y a les où vivent
les les musulmans il y a aussi hélas des
imams qui vient des pays qui soutiennent
le vahabisme c'est avant tout l'Arabie
saoudite le Qatar on les connaît très
bien ce sont ces payslà qui sont
derrière cette agitation alors il faut
d'abord
chasser des mauvais imames et deuxè
deuxièement préparer les imames il faut
faire faut qu'il y ait une école o on
prépare les qui prêchent ça c'est une
vraiment un problème commun avec vous et
ça c'est c'est très important
bon maintenant oui est-ce qu'on peut se
permettre une question
complémentaire qu'est-ce que c'est que
da vu de
euh et est-ce que la vision de daesh de
Moscou est exactement la même que celle
qu'on peut avoir ici on entend notamment
dire en France par certains que
finalement l'aspect
islamiste de DAEs n'est peut-être pas
aussi important qu'on le dit et que
derrière il y a ces gens sont manipulés
par d'anciens militaires policiers
irakiens syrien et cetera quelle est
votre vision de daesh écoutez il y a
deux choses je crois que d'abord
daesh l'état islamique ce sont des
fanatiques pour nous avant tout ce sont
des fanatiques ce sont des extrémistes
musulmans euh avec les idées qu'on peut
pas accepter c'est c'est c'est la
barbarie c'est c'est la même chose que
que le
nazisme pendant la 2ème guerre mondiale
mais sans doute c'est une force
politique qui est manipulé par les
autres c'est ça le problème on aurait pu
venir au bout de daesh il y a déjà
longtemps s'il n'avait pas des
protecteurs extérieurs des pays qui
manipulent qui se serent de daesh pour
combattre Assad c'est tout à fait clair
c'est-à-dire que il y a deux choses il y
a de choses il y a alors le phénomène
lui-même l'islam radical daesh qui qui
est inspiré par lesidabit salafit qui
viennent de l'Arabie Saoudite du Qatar
et puis il y a les pays Arabie Saoudite
dit et le Qatar mais aussi certains
d'autres pays plutôt vers l'Ouest qui
les manipulent qui les utilise à leur
fin géopolitique c'est clair et là le
jeu le double jeu de la Turquie il est
tout à fait évidente alors le Turquie un
membre de
l'OTAN un membre de la coalition et en
même temps le premier complice de daesh
aujourd'hui nous on a été les premiers à
le dire mais maintenant je vois que même
les Américains le disent ouvertement ils
appellent Erdogan à fermer la frontière
entre la Syrie et la Turquie puisque par
cette frontière d'abord passe les les
terroristes les armes et puis transit le
pétrole volé écoutez c'est une
complicité c'est une complicité évidente
et alors vous avez posé la question sur
Erdogan c'est vrai que c'est un frais
musulman et on le découvre de plus en
plus et les Frères musulmans c'est une
force redoutable et très dangereuse on
parle de daesh mais il y a la variété
bon DAEs c'est c'est disons le plus
connu mais il y a en nousra il y a
d'autres groupes groupement terroristes
qui sont de la même de la même deson qui
ont des mêmes idées ce sont des filiales
de al-qaïa et les autres il y a beaucoup
de groupes terroristes on peut pas
parler uniquement de DAEs daesh a
beaucoup de de de d'alliés sur le
terrain il faut les re
tous et les mots là vous avez pas
répondu sur à quoi les mot là l'Iran bah
les mot là l'Iran bah je peux dire que
roméie rominiie a vécu en France avant
de partir en Iran alors la France a raté
une occasion mais pour être sérieux je
je dis que nous la Russie n'a jamais
partagé euh les idées des imams en Iran
jamais
on on fait la distinction entre un pays
son peuple et ses dirigeants que ce soit
pour tout pays et alors euh on n'a
jamais partagé les idées extrémistes et
euh bon des des imemes de de l'Iran mais
par contre l'Iran c'est notre voisin
c'est un pays pour qui on a énormément
du respect c'est une des civilisations
de l'humanité c'est une des plus
vieilles civilisations c'est un peuple
qui est digne de tout notre respect et
moi je pense que tous les pays dans leur
évolution ont connu des des moment
difficil politiquement alors l'Iran est
en train de vivre un moment peut-être
difficile mais c'est une civilisation
qui a été qui va rester et nous som nous
sommes tout à fait prêts à coopérer avec
l'Iran d'ailleurs la Russie a joué un
rôle très important pour trouver la
solution du nucléaire irindien vous le
savez très
bien
euh Jacques Blamont de l'Académie des
Sciences Monsieur l'Ambassadeur la
Russie et la France s'apprête à célébrer
cette année le 50e anniversaire de la
signature de l'accord spatial entre
l'Union soviétique l'Académie des
Sciences de l'Union soviétique et le
général de Gaulle don j'étais l'honneur
d'être un des
négociateurs ne pensez-vous pas monsieur
ambassadeur que ce serait l'occasion
pour la Russie et la France de proposer
une initiative politique dans le domaine
de l'espace l'espace est devenu très
important au point de vue aussi bien
économique que militaire mais toute la
partie dis exploration y compris homme
dans l'espace souffre à l'heure actuelle
d'un manque de souffle politique ne
serait-il pas possible d'utiliser cet
anniversaire pour dépasser les
cérémonies et pour au contraire proposer
quelque chose de concret merci merci
merci beaucoup
alors c'est c'est vrai mais c'est ça
sera pour l'année prochaine le 50e
anniversaire de de l'accord de la
coopération spatiale entre l'Union
soviétique à l'époque et la France a été
signé lors du voyage du général de
Gaulle à Moscou je crois au mois de juin
66 alors c'était un voyage très très
très mémorable c'était un une sorte de
point de départ de nos relations et je
peux vous dire que notre coopération
dans le domaine spatial avec la France
est la plus importante la plus
avancée parmi tous les pays du monde y
compris les États-Unis alors nous
continuons cette
coopération sans doute on va on va
prévoir toute une série de de
célébrations l'année prochaine et je
vous invite à m'approcher après pour me
donner votre carte pour que je puisse
vous inviter puisqu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'on va faire on va inviter tous
les cosmonautes français les les Russes
bon beaucoup de choses mais sur le plan
bilatéral je je veux pas dévoiler des
secrets mais il y a des choses qui se
préparent il y a des choses qui se
préparent pour l'année prochaine sur le
plan bilatéral pour commémorer cette
date très importante maintenant euh pour
l'exploration de de de l'espace
elle-même bah je dirais
que on est moins ambitieux aujourd'hui
qu'il y a 50 ans il y a 50 ans on vou
est aller sur la lune sur le mars sur le
Vénus et cetera aujourd'hui l'espace est
beaucoup plus pragmatique il y a
énormément de satellites y compris la
satellite pour la diffusion de de de
télévision de de la radio on peut plus
vivre sans sans les satellites mais il
n'y a plus de ces grandes rêves
spatiales qu'on a eu il y a 50 ans ceci
est exp on peut expliquer en partie par
par le manque d'argent parce queé là il
y a les pays sont tellement endettés il
y a beaucoup de beaucoup d'autres soucis
on peut plus dépenser autant d'argent
qu'on a dépensé pour l'espace il y a 50
ans mais je crois que ça reste un
domaine très très important très très
important et nous sommes conscient qu'on
peut faire beaucoup de choses et on le
fait déjà avec la France sur ce
domaineel une question sur les zones
plus froide le passage du dit du
nord-est en l'artile russe notamment euh
une cinquantaine de navires peuvent
passer tous les ans dans cette région
quel est par rapport à 18000 suè 11000
Panama quelle est la la position et
l'envie de de la Russie dans dans ce
domaine en terme de trafic maritime au
vu des des changements climatiques des
possibilités qui qui qui s'offre dans
dans ces régions est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment une volonté de développer
quelque chose est-ce que c'est possible
que que que se passe-t-il bah écoutez
nous nous nous préparons nous nous
préparons à ces changements dont dont
vous parlez il est vrai que avec un
certain réchauffement en
Arctique la possibilité de d'utiliser la
voie du nord est de plus en plus grande
il y a de plus en plus de navir qui
passent mais il y a il y a il y a deux
choses c'est une région qui est très
fragile parce que la nature anarctique
est très très très fragile
et moi je pense je crains je crains que
si on va aller vers une exploitation de
la voie maritime d'une heure d'une façon
euh incontrôlée ça peut provoquer de
vrais désastres écologiques alors euh il
faut se préparer mais il faut se parler
de ça il faut se préparer aussi sur le
plan de d'organisation de ce trafic faut
pas que ce il faut que ce soit bien
contrôlé on trouve quelques accords
communs il y a aussi le problème de des
des peuples autochtones parce que le
Grand Nord
arctique est habité par par par le par
le peuple
euh on dit les peuples premi je crois
sont vraiment des gens qui ont gardé
leur mode de vie ancestral que nous
avons tous et là oublié et là il y a un
très très très grand savant français
Jean mollery qui est une autorité que
que je connais bien que j'aime bien
euh qui a fait énormément pour protéger
l'Arctique pour protéger ces peuple
autochtone c'est aussi un problème si
euh cette région souffre trop à notre
civilisation entre guillemet je pense je
crains qu'on va les tuer tout simplement
on va les tuer ce sont des quelques
milliers de gens mais qui sont attachés
à leur mode de vie c'est un un autre
problème et puis sur le plan économique
euh je crois que bon certes la voie
maritime du Nord est plus courte que la
voie du Sud mais il y a d'autres moyens
et notamment le chemin de fer le fameux
transibérien c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant nous sommes actuellement de
travailler à doubler la capacité du
transibérien je sais que la Chine aussi
est en train de construire cette Groie
cette nouvelle voie de de soi
c'est-à-dire on peut moi j'utiliserai
plus le chemin de fer que cette voie
maritime qui qui reste quand même assez
assez assez fragile tandis que le chemin
de fer c'est c'est vraiment c'est c'est
le transport de l'avenir écologique
rapide pratique tout je vais rebondir je
vais rebondir sur l'Artique euh
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
le déploiement de batterie de missile
S400 dans l'Arctique et si j'ai encore
un petit peu de temps les dernières
révélations de Wikileaks concernant
Erdogan et le souscoil 24 qui a été
abattu à la
frontière je vous écoute alors pour le
déploiement des des armes en Arctique
écoutez nous nous protégeons nous nous
protégeons parce que euh nous savons
très bien que la le temps ces derniers
temps s'intéresse beaucoup à l'Arctique
que
euh on commence à dire mais c'est c'est
pas bon que l'Arctique dépend uniquement
des pays rivérins nous avons tous le
droit d'exploiter
et vu le passé comment on on a voulu
employer la force pour s'affirmir
quelque part n nous prenons des
précautions encore une fois les armes
que vous avez mentionné ce sont des
armes défensives ce sont des armes
défensives avant tout contre les aéros
neuf qui peuvent être utilisés à des fin
pas du tout
Pacifique pour les révélations de Vik
si vous pouvez me préciser de de quoi
exactement il s'agit euh Erdogan
surveillait le les déplacement d'avion
russes à sa frontière depuis 6 semaines
et avait la ferme intention de s'en
faire un
oui
oui oui j'ai vu ça on a dit que Erdogan
faisait ça à partir du mois d'octobre
dernier puisque était avant les
élections et puis il voulait utiliser ce
fait pour les élections mais je constate
je constate que l'avion a été abattu
après que Erdogan était déjà réélu
c'està-dire bon j'ai confiance à vikilix
mais
euh ça coule pas très bien par contre ce
que nous a beaucoup préoccupé et le
président Poutine en a parlé
publiquement à des conférences de presse
que pour notre opération en Syrie nous
sommes en coordination avec les
États-Unis qui sont à la tête d'une
coalition et nous fournissons
l'information sur les plans de vol de
nos avions en Syrie aux
Américains et là président Poutine s'est
posé la question comment ça se fait que
ces plans de vol étaient connu par les
Turcs parce que notre avion était bien
attendu par le Turc c'était une
provocation préméitée ça c'est il n a
pas de doute mais cette loyauté des
Américains mais surtout des des Turcs
vis-à-vis des
Russes ça pose ça pose beaucoup de
problèmes ça pose beaucoup de questions
comment on peut faire une confiance
entre alliés si on commence à à abattre
les aviens des uns et des autres ça
c'est c'est un vrai problème et moi je
pense que la Turquie Erdogan
personnellement a fait une erreur
colossale colossal pourquoi parce que la
Turquie et président Erdogan ont été
considéré par nous comme des alliés dans
la lutte contre daesh comme un part
partenur économique important et aussi
comm pays
ami de semaines avant que notre avion
était abattu le président Poutine a eu
une très bon rencontre avec Erdogan
Antalia en marche de G20 ils ont
longuement parlé ils ont ils ont signé
plusieurs accords et alors ce coup dans
le dos a été ressenti par la Russie
comme une
trahison c'est pire qu'une INCI
une provocation c'est une trahison et
pourquoi l'ont-ils fait à votre avis et
alors et vous savez que les traîtres ils
sont méprisé par tous et je crois que
c'est pour ça que je disdogan a fait une
faute
irréparable irréparable pour lui pas
pour la Turquie que la Turquie ça reste
un pays amis avec qui nous sommes tout à
fait prêt à développer nos relations
mais avec Erdogan c'est fini pourquoi
pourquoi elle a fait pour plusieurs
raisons mais moi je crois que la la la
la raison la plus
plausible c'est qu'on a commencé à
toucher
à à l'argent qu'il percevait de la
contrebande du pétrole on sait très bien
que toute cette pétrole volé en Irak et
en Syrie transite par la Turquie et la
Turquie met dans la poche des sommes
très considérables et dans nos dans n
dans médiia on parlait
ouvertement de l'implication de la
famille d'Erdogan dans ce business son
fils son Beaufils qui est ministre du du
pétrole je crois toute tout le clan
Erdogan s'est enrichi énormément grâce à
cette contrebande et quand on a commencé
à toucher le pétrole il a réagi pour
montrer son mécontentement pour dire
attention si vous allez plus loin
Erdogan se croit vraiment à la tête
d'une empire
ottomane vous savez il y a un proverbe
français qui dit il y a des yeux plus
grands que le ventre voilà c'est c'est
bien le
cas Monsieur l'Ambassadeur bonjour Henri
pomerin consultant international ma
question rejoint également la relation
entre la Russie et la Turquie à la suite
de ce terrible incident le président
Erdogan a refusé catégoriquement de
présenter des excuse il a présenté
seulement ses condoléances euh les
sanctions décidées par le président
Poutine vont sévèrement toucher
l'économie turque et sachant également
que la majeure partie des Frères
musulmans sont reçus hébergés en Turquie
quel est votre point de vue sur la
sortie de cette crise et comment
voyez-vous l'évolution euh de la
relation la Russie vient d'annoncer
qu'elle fera participer des experts
internationaux à l'ouverture de la boîte
noir pour prouver probablement sa bonne
foi quelle est votre vision sur la
sortie de
crise
écoutez je commence par la fin de votre
question on na pas besoin d'ouvrir la
boîte noire puisque un pilote le
navigateur qui était dans l'avion est
vivant il a déjà tout dit on n pas
besoin de bîes noir il a très bien dit
clairement dit qu'il n'a eu aucun
avertissement avant que l'avion soit
descendu que ils ont tiré dans le
dos les pilotes s'attendait pas du tout
à être attaqué par qui que ce soit que
l'avion été abattu sur le territoire de
la Syrie il est tombé sur le territoire
de la Syrie on n pas besoin de d'ouvrir
les boîtes noires c'est c'est c'est
clair comment sortir moi écoutez encore
une fois je je crois qu'il faut il faut
regarder à la longue dans une
perspective longue et sans doute nous
allons nous allons conserver et
développer nos relations avec la avec la
Turquie mais pas avec Erdogan lui lui
c'est c'est fu je pense c'est perdu
c'est c'est c'est fu si vous savez euh
c'est un point de vue tout à fait
personnel mais euh ça me rappelle un peu
l'histoire de
sarkashwiili qui était le président de
la geéorgie quand la geéorgie a attaqué
le sitatut du Sud la Russie n'a plus eu
aucun contact avec lui tant qu'il n'est
pas
parti moi je encore une fois c'est c'est
moi un plus strictement personnel mais
je pense qu'il n'a rien à
espéré mais pas la Turquie avec la
Turquie on va continuer à développer des
relations sans doute
on su Monsieur l'Ambassadeur Michel
Ferrand avocat deux questions la
première est-ce que Vladimir Poutine a
engagé il y a plusieurs années un effort
de de reconstruction de de l'institution
militaire russe pour la la ramener pas
tout à fait au niveau de ce qu'était
l'exurs enfin plus que ce qu'elle a été
à la fin de la perest Troïa en tout cas
est-ce que est-ce que la Russie
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas en train de
surutiliser le capital matériel était
disponible qui encore largement
postsoviétique dans le cadre des
opérations syriennes et est-ce que
l'effort qui est actuellement consenti
en Syrie est un effort qui peut être
tenu dans la durée étant donné les les
contraintes budgétaires de la défense en
Russie donc ça c'était ma première
question la la deuxème question c'est
alors je sais pas si vous répondrez mais
c'est votre appréciation sur la
diplomatie française que je perçois
personnellement comme étant d'une très
grande
faiblesse et et et et depuis fort
longtemps si vous voulez on a souvent
dit il y a 30 40 ans que un diplomate
français prenait ses ordres ou à Moscou
ou ou à Washington aujourd'hui je pense
pas que ça soit le cas mais c'est plutôt
la diplomatie du chéquier et et je pense
que dans dans certains traités qu'on a
passé récemment sous les deux présid
récente il y a la cine de la diplomatie
du chéquier en provenance de certains
pays enfin typiquement Arabie Saoudite
et Qatar est-ce que on est réellement
indépendant est-ce qu'on est crédible
alors qu'on pratique le tête à queue
diplomatique à peu près tous les 2 ans
bon pour pour pour la première pour la
première question bah je dirais
heureusement heureusement que le
président Poutine ét assez prévoyant
pour commencer cet effort pour rebâtir
la puissance militaire de la Russie il y
a quelques années déjà on voit à quel
point on en a besoin aujourd'hui et là
je je je crois que si la Russie n'avait
pas une force militaire suffisante et
ben elle aurait connu le sort de la
yoslavie parce que c'est le fait que la
Russie
à l'arme nucléaire que c'est un pays
fort déterminé a refroidi plusieurs tête
dans le monde puisque à les entendre à
les écouter il aurait pu faire ce qu'ils
ont fait à killè ou en Yougoslavie en
Russie heureusement que nous sommes
forts hélas nous avons essay on est vous
savez les Russes des slaves sont
romantique un peu naïf et on a été très
naïf du temps de Gorbatchev Gorbatchev
que je je me souviens de lui puisque bon
je peux pas dire que cétais un proche
mais je l'accompagnais quand il est venu
en France et j'étais à Strasbourg au
Conseil de l'Europe quand il a parlé de
de de la maison commune on ne pensait
que une fois débarrassé de l'idéologie
communiste l'urope va nous accueillir
les bras ouverts et que ça sera un
paradis sur la terre et rien ne s'est
passé rien on a vu que on a applaudi on
a dit bah vous êtes gentil vous êtes
très très bien on a tout mis dans la
poche sans nous donner rien en retour et
c'est pour ça que hélas il faut être
fort pour être respecté il faut être
fort c'est une banalité triste mais il n
a pas d'autrees alors euh quelle arme
nous nous utilisons bah écoutez on a vu
qu'on a en utilisé des des armes
différentes sans doute les avions qu'on
utilise ce sont des avions qui ont déjà
un certain âge mais qui sont très
performants qui restent très très
performants mais en même temps je crois
que utiliser cette arme à en vraie
guerre c'est aussi une expérience tout à
fait inestimable pour toute armée que ce
soit l'armée française américaine russes
moi je crois je crois que notre effort
militaire elle est juste suffisant pour
des missions qui ont été euh qui ont été
donnés à nos forces en Syrie euh pour
votre deuxième question qui est une
question
bon très délicate vous savez que les
diplomates français je les pratique
depuis 40 ans et ce sont des partenaires
des collègues souvent des amis des des
vrais amis je veux pas apporter des
jugements sur sur leurs compéten ce sont
la France la diplomatie française a été
toujours très très très respecté dans le
monde et la tradition diplomatique
française a été une des une des
meilleures on a on a toujours des bonnes
relations avec les diplomates français
je pense qu'ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
mais encore une fois et bon pour pour
les ordres ça on a exagéré ils nont
jamais reçu des ordres de Moscou ça je
peux le jurer mais h
l'indépendance de la France peut-être
n'est pas la même qu'il y a 40 ans parce
que le monde a évolué j'ai déjà parlé de
de l'évolution de l'Union européenne de
cette délégation d'une grande partie de
la souveraineté dans le domaine de la
politique internationale à Bruxelles ce
qui a à mon avis affaibli la France
parce que la force de la France on on se
souvenu de du général de Gaulle la la
force de la France conséit au fait qu'il
avait une politique indépendante
vis-àvis vie de l'Union soviétique qu'il
pourrait parler avec l'Union soviétique
sans demander la viis de des autres
c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui pour
différentes raisons non pas à cause des
diplomates qui sont mauvais non la
situation a changé puis la France a
rejoint la partie militaire de l'OT temp
le commandant intégré de l'OT temp c'est
aussi sal liit sal liit l'autonomie
l'indépendance de la France c'est pas à
moi et ses jugements mais sur le plan
objectif c'est bien le
fait que la France aujourd'hui est moins
indépendante vous avez parlé et à mon
avis à juste titre que les pays comme
Arabie saoudite et le Qatar qui n'a
jamais été des grands acteurs
internationaux grâce à l'argent à des
investissements très très importants en
France sans doute considéré par la
France comme des partenaires importants
il faut tenir compte de leurs intérêts
mais les intérêts dearabie Saoudite de
Qatar sont pas toujours les mêmes que
ceux de la France parfois même ils sont
contradictoires le monde est trop
compliqué pour donner une réponse disons
nette et CLA à votre question mais la
question elle est tout à fait
pertinente Cécile maison neuve centre
énergie de l'Institut français des
relations internationales j'aimerais
vous revenir au Moyen-Orient et vous
interroger sur sur le développement de
l'énergie nucléaire civile dans cette
région puisque la Russie en est l'un des
principaux acteurs que ce soit à boucher
en Turquie en Jordanie ou plus récemment
en Égypte quel regard portez-vous sur
les projets dans le nucléaire civil d'un
pays comme l'Arabie
Saoudite euh d'abord pour pour l'énergie
nucléaire je crois j crois j crois je
pense que l'énergie nucléaire cont
irement ce qu'on peut entendre c'est
c'est l'énergie de l'avenir c'est
vraiment l'énergie propre l'énergie sûre
et l'énergie bon marché et au lieu de de
de de faire beaucoup de gadgets ils vont
mieux développer des sources d'énergie
qu'on sait faire et la France dans le
domaine du nucléaire civil est un des
des pays les plus avancés dans le monde
il y a
ces pi on peut les compter par les par
les doigts d'une main et alors c'est
bien que la France n'a pas
abandonné cette cette source d'énergie
et je peux vous dire qu'il y a une vraie
coopération dans le domaine de l'énergie
nucléaire entre la Russie et la France
pour la construction des centrales
nucléaires en Arabie Saoudite par je
crois que comme tout État comme l'Iran
comme tout État a le droit développer le
nucléaire civil moi je Seris je pense
que ça sera plutôt bien parce que
aujourd'hui l'Arabie Saoudite avant tout
le producteur du pétrole et on sait que
le pétrole c'est une source
d'énergie qui est disons pas très
compatible avec le problème de
réchauffement climatique et et là s'il
sera moins dépendant s voit moins
extraire du pétrole
et développer des sources d'énergie
nucléaire il y a deux avantages que je
vois le premier est qu'il y aura moins
de pétrole ce qui va rendre le pétrole
plus cher et nous nous sommes intéressés
que les prix montent mais en même temps
qu'on développe un source d'énergie
propre et d'avenir moi je suis tout à
fait
favorablejet ah oui changement de sujet
à K juriste
enchanté quelle est la vue de de Moscou
sur la décision de donner le prix Nobel
de littérature de setlana
alexovic bon alors tout à fait positif
tout à fait positif c'est une dame qui a
bien mérité je je pense ce
prix nous sommes contents que ce prix
était attribué à un écrvain une écrévin
d'un pays issu de l'ancienne l'Union
soviétique c'est-à-dire les gens qui
sont de la même C s que nous moi je j'ai
pas commenté ces décisions mais pour moi
elle est plutôt positive ça a été bien
vu ça pas posé des problèmes comme avec
paste Nar à
l'époque Anne tu une
question du coup je me permets
d'enchaîner puisquon est sur la
culture ah bon
d'accord PASC je temps indépendant euh
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur toute ma vie
toute ma jeunesse j'ai été bercé par
l'amitié franco-russe j'ai appris le
russe à l'école après j'ai travaillé au
knè j'ai étudié le théâtre et cetera et
et pour moi le le l'amitié francorusse a
toujours eu une dimension artistique et
culturelle très importante et depuis un
certain temps alors que j'adorais le
cinéma russe et la littérature russe et
cetera depuis un certain temps je ne le
perçois plus et j'ai l'impression que la
Russie n'a plus le temps pour l'art ou
alors plus le temps ou le désir de le
partager avec le reste du monde
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire là-dessus oui
non écoutez je peux vous
rassurer qu'il y a toujours de de la
culture de la littérature et du cinéma
en Russie je crois que c'est une
perception du à mass média française qui
n'en parle
plus en général quand on vit en France
on constate que que la Russie n'existe
pas on n'en parle pas ou bien on dit des
choses on dit du mal on du mal on dit
rien mais en fait la vie artistique en
Russie est aussi riche qu'il y a il y a
il y a toujours et en France même en
France il y a dans plusieurs villes des
semaines ou même des festivals du cinéma
russe et on vient d'avoir je crois le
22e édition déjà
du festival du du cinéma rus à enfleur
en
Normandie il a eu euh il y a un mois un
mois et demi une semaine du cinéma russe
aux Harlekin le le cinéma Harlekin là on
fait cette semaine deux fois par an où
on présente les les les les nouveaux
films russes c'estàdire les gens qui
aiment le cinéma russe qui aiment le
cinéma soviétique ont toujours la la
possibilité de de de voir ces films mais
malheureusement peut-être on fait pas
assez de communication mais surtout les
médias français n'en parlent pas c'est
pour ça vous avez cette impression que
ça n'existe pas si ça existe
et comme ami de la Russie je vous invite
de de venir tout simplement dans mon
pays passez pas 24 he mais quelques
jours vous baladez à Moscou ou balader
dans d'autres villes de la Russie voir
les expositions voir la vie artistique
et
autant riche sinon plus riche qu'en
France énormément il y a beaucoup de
richesse alors nous nous sommes en train
de préparer pour juste pour un exemple
et fait pour
annonce on est en train de préparer deux
très très grandes expositions pour
l'année prochaine la première à Paris à
la Fondation Louis Vuitton pour le mois
d'octobre prochain on prépare une
exposition de la collection chukin
chukin c'était un messen russe du début
du 20e siècle qui collectionnait
l'art français impressionniste poste
impressionniste et sa collection est une
des meilleures au monde et alors ça sera
une cette
exposition à la Fondation Luis Vuitton
sera un événement mondial il y a une
autre
exposition qui se prépare à Moscou au
musée poukin pour le décembre prochain
c'est une sur André mer et son musée
imaginaire ça c'est Madame Antonova une
très très très grande dame qui prépare
cette exposition ce sera aussi un
événement mondial et moi je pense que ce
sont des événements qui sont dignes de
la présence de nos présidents pour
inaugurer ces expositions bon je parle
pas de tourné des des ballets des des
artistes rus à travers la France tout le
temps je pense que chaque jour il y a
quelqu'un en France un artiste russe en
France mais encore une fois le problème
on parle pas on n parle pas c'est ça le
problème-ce que je vais je vais revenir
sur le côté géopolitique et diplomatique
Laurent Fabius qui dit Jabal nostra fait
un très bon boulot sur le terrain jab
quoi Jabal nostra fait du très bon
boulot sur le terrain ouis ça vous fait
penser à quoi quand vous vous retrouvez
maintenant à table avec lui qu'on est
dans la nouvelle alliance demande plus
le départ
d'Assad c'est quoi c'est c'est une élite
American minded c'est quelqu'un qui
reçoit sesor de Bruxelles c'est quoi ça
il faut poser ces questions à lui-même
vous savez Fabius il est tous les jours
quelque part au micro alors vous posez
cette question à lui vous voyez traiti
moi moi je je ce que je constate que
quand le président se rencontre François
Hollande et Vladimir Poutine ils sont
complètement sur la même longueur d'onde
et ils comprennent très bien que pour
résoudre le problème de la Syrie il faut
suivre de deux traits comme on dit de
voix une voix d'abord militaire pour
venir au bout de daesh mais pas
uniquement de daesh mais tous les les
complices tous les alliés de daesh qui
sont nombreux et
parallèlement préparer les changements
politiques alors les changements
politiques en syérie c'est avant tout on
travaille actuellement sur deux choses
la constitution de deux listes une liste
des des opposants pour former enfin la
délégation pour négocier avec le
gouvernement
syrien la transition la préparation de
la syérie nouvelle et 2ème liste des
organisation terroriste qu'il faut
combattre parce que euh ce ant dans la
presse occidentale on dit bah les Russes
bombardent pas les mauvais bombardent
les bons nous disons mais écoutez
donnez-moi une listes qui nous devons
bombarder et qui ne devons pas
bombarder aucune réponse heureusement
qu'on a bougé et lors de la dernière
rencontre à Vienne on a décidé justement
de dresser cette liste il y a déjà une
ébauche de cette liste qui existe aux
Nations Unies puisque Nations Unies il y
a la liste des organisations qui sont
considérées comme des organisations
terroristes alors cette tâche était
confiée à Jordanie c'est un pays à qui
nous avons beaucoup de confiance et je
crois qu'il y travaille pour préparer
une liste de ces
organisations la liste des des des
opposants a été confiée ou plutôt c'est
l'Arabie saoudite a dit c'est nous c'est
nous qui nous allons faire cette liste
on dit très bien il faut il faut les
encourager mais il faudrait que dans
cette affaire soit aussi impliqué le
représentant spécial du du secrétaire
génal des Nations Unies du Mistra Mura
qui qu'il prépare ensemble chez liste et
la prochaine fois quand le groupe de
soutien du processus politique en Syrie
le groupe de Vienne va se réunir
peut-être encore avant la fin de cette
année normalement ils doivent considérer
voir ces listes et là
on avancera encore une fois je pense bon
il y a des nuances il y a des nuances
dans les déclarations de tel ou tel
homme politique responsable français on
va pas commenter chaque nuance mais sur
la ligne général je constate que parmi
tous les pays occidentaux la France est
le pays le plus proche de nous et
d'ailleurs c'est pas par hasard que
c'est le seul pays que
tine appelle le pays allié et moi je je
me souviens que ça été ça été publique
quand on a décidé de combattre ensemble
daesh d'autres groupes terroristes en
Syrie président Poutine a donné les
ordres à nos forces militaires en disant
alors vous devez coopérer avec nos amis
français sur le terrain comme avec des
alliés et ça c'était un vrai tournant un
vrai tournant maintenant on dit que le
président François Hollande n'a pas
réussi à faire les grande coalition non
il a fait il a réussi très bien il a
réussi très très bien on n jamais parlé
de faire une coalition sur le commandem
d'un tel et tel pays non coalition ça
veut dire qu'il y a plusieurs pays qui
poursuivent le même objectif en série
elles peuvent travailler parallèlement
mais pour le même objectif et le mot clé
c'est la coordination c'est la
coordination et ça je peux vous dire que
en Syrie entre la Russie et la France il
y a une vraie coordination au bien
autant sur le niveau politique que au
niveau militaire et là c'est un progrès
indéniable jeangill
oui Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur nous n'avons pas encore
parlé des États-Unis d'Amérique c'est
quand même fantastique donc je je je
ramènerai les États-Unis d'Amérique à
travers les relations Europe États-Unis
Russie beaucoup de gens estiment qu'il y
a un rôle ambigu des États-Unis il a des
hommes politiques français he Sarkozi
disait en janvier le le les les les
relations russes sont essentielles les
intérêts des Américains en Europe sont
pas les intérêts des Européens vis-à-vis
des Russes et Valérie giscardisttin en
mai disait que que les relations avec
l'Europe et la Russie se passerait mieux
si Bruxelles était plus indépendant
euh comment regardez-vous ce ce jeu des
Américains en Europe quel est selon vous
l'objectif poursuivi je parle États-Unis
Europe et comment États-Unis autant et
comment comptez-vous y
répondre B écoutez le jeu le jeu
géopolitique des Américains je crois
elle est elle est assez assez claire
puisque le problème avec les Américains
euh ce que les Américains euh ne
considère pas les autres pays comme les
pays égaux c'est ça le problème
c'està-dire il se croit toujours les
premiers les plus forts les plus
intelligents bah écoutez il veut il y a
cette volonté de
domination qui empêche beaucoup de
choses on a rien contre l'Amérique un
pis comme les autres il a le droit de se
développer de faire ce qu'ils veulent
mais il faut pas faire des leçons aux
autres comment elle doit vivre il faut
pas imposer leur volonté aux autres euh
par la force c'est ça le problème mais
hélas on voit que l'Amérique ne change
pas comme s'il ne voyez pas le monde
changer aujourd'hui euh je crois que
l'erreur
fondamentale était oh là là euh l'erreur
fondamentale était que à la fin de la
guerre froide les Américains ont pensé
qu'ils ont gagné la guerre et comme et
comme disons le le pays qui a remporté
cette victoire ils peuvent faire tout ce
qu'ils veulent d'abord euh la guerre
froid je crois tout le monde a gagné et
le pays le pays qui a perdu la guerre
froide n'existe plus
c'était l'Union soviétique il n'existe
plus à la place de l'Union soviétique il
y a plusieurs autres pays certes la
Russie a hérité beaucoup de l'Union
soviétique mais pas l'idéologie de
l'Union soviétique c'est plus un pays
communiste c'est plus un pays avec cette
idée messianique de convertir tout le
monde au communisme parce que c'est ça
qui posait le problème du temps de la
guerre froide c'est plus le cas mais les
Américains peut-être qu'ils sont trop
loin de nous ils n'ont pas remarqué ce
changement et je pense je pense que ceci
constitue un problème pas uniquement
dans relation avec la Russie mais avec
tous les autres pays du monde parce que
nous vouons tous être traités comme les
pays
égaux maintenant
euh il y a il y a
aussi des problèmes par exemple entre
l'Europe et l'Amérique que l'Amérique
commence à
utiliser les armes je dirais économiques
pour mettre les pays européens dans le
rang je je parle d'exemple des des des
sanctions qui ont été imposées à
certaines banques françaises ce qui est
tout à fait scandaleux mais c'est
scandaleux que
l'Amérique demande à d'autres pays de
bire à leur lois à leur juridiction
cette
extr de leur judiction e un vrai
problème un vrai problème et ceci a ceci
a complètement tétanisé la France Les
Français aujourd'hui ont peur de faire
les affaires avec la Russie par crainte
qu'ils ont être sanctionnés par
l'émérique voyez
HL l'éérique sous plusieurs aspects joue
un rôle plutôt négatif dans cette
évolution du monde si je peux me
permettre dans dans ce que vous venez de
dire on entend en creux le fait que la
Russie elle n'a pas cette volonté
hégémonique que tout ça c'est du passé
c'était l'Union soviétique et je sais
pas si vous regardez la télévision de
temps en temps il y a une série en ce
moment qui s'appelle occupi moi j'ai pas
encore regardé mais enfin j'ai j'ai cru
comprendre qu'on imagine euh une une
Russie un petit peu un petit peu
impérialiste il reste des craintes vous
en êtes conscients dans les pays baltes
dans d'ancienne République qui étaient
dans l'orbite soviétique qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire aujourd'hui sur ce
thème sur ce sur ce que sont où s'arrête
les frontières l'influence de la Russie
écoutez premièrement je regarde pas
beaucoup la télévision
heureusement heureusement parce que vous
savez vous avez peut-être entendu dire
parler de de
grande Crévin russe
Boulgakov et dans le cœur du chien le
professeur dit que si vous voulez être
du bon humeur ne laissz jamais la presse
soviétique alure c'est une c'est un
principe auquel je suis fidèle que ce
soit la France ou l'Union soviétique
c'est pour ça que sans doute j'ai pas vu
cette série c'est suré
maintenant mais maintenant
alors sur la pour les choses plus
sérieuses bah écoutez il y a on a
l'impression de qu'il y a toujours dans
la tête des gens surtout en Occident un
P virtuel qui n'existe pas mais qu'il
attaque tout le
temps c'est ce pays méchant qui veut
attaquer tout le monde qui est un pays
agressif et par force d'y croire ils ont
créé dans leur tête mais ce qui est
mauvais ils essaient de faire ça dans
les tête de leur lecteurs qu'il existe
ce pays mais qu'il n'existe pas écoutez
la Russie d'abord sur le plan de la
domination qui est le notre intérêt à
une expansion on a le territoire le plus
plus grand au monde qui pour la moitié
n'est pas encore défraîchi il y a tant
de choses à faire chez nous qu'on n' pas
ni volonté ni des moyens pour le faire
savez que toute cette partie orientale
la Sibérie c'est ça va prendre des
décennies pour pour
disons développer sur le plan économique
cette partie de on a aucun intérêt il
faut être logique il faut t essayer de
comprendre l'autre qu son quelle est sa
logique il y a aucune logique pour les
pays baltes mais il représente rien pour
nous ce sont des pays de tout petit pays
de tout petit pays ils n'ont rien ni ni
aucun intérêt àer aller envahir bon ce
sont nos voisins on peut pas changer la
géographie nous sommes tout à fait prêts
à développer les relation avec eux
d'autant plus que au sein de ces pays il
y a des millions et des millions de
Russes qui vivent il y a aucune raison
pour que les russis veulent faire
quelque chose contre ces pay non ce sont
des fantasmes des phobies des complexes
mais pour ces pays c'est une façon de se
faire vooir sur le plan
international plus il cri attention la
Russie voit nous attaquer plus les pays
font attention alors oui oui il existe
il faut les aider il faut les protéger
c'est leur un peu face de de de vivre
mais il faut pas tomber dans ce
piège toute dernière
question bonjour Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
Lionel bianquy jeune diplômé j'aurais
aimé savoir comment vous comptiez régler
le cas des territoires contrôlés par les
Kurdes lors de la future transition
politique qui aura en Syrie après le
conflit très bonne question
alors tout d'abord tout d'abord nous
sommes nous avons toujours été nous
sommes toujours les amis du peuple
kurde nous pensons que c'est un peuple
qui digne tout notre respect c'est un
peuple qui se bat depuis longtemps pour
avoir un État
indépendant les frontières dans cette
région du monde ont été tracées d'une
façon assez artificielle d'ailleurs
c'est pas uniquement là en Afrique aussi
dans d'autres cas aussi peut-être mais
c'est difficile de bouger des frontières
on sait que ça amène souvent à des
guerre il faut il faut il faut trouver
une solution il faut trouver une
solution ça me rappelle bon il y a un
certain parallélisme entre le problème
palestinien et le problème du peuple
courde ce sont deux peuples de grands
peuples qui méritent avoir leur patrie
comment faire ça je ne sais pas je peux
pas vous dire mais il faut être assez
imaginatif moi je pense que mais encore
une fois c'est strictement personnel moi
je pense que dans ce grande travail
diplomatique qui doit se faire au
prochorient il faut traiter pas
uniquement les questions de la Syrie
mais la toutes les questions qui sont là
parce que si on on laisse du côté le le
problème palestinien le problème kurde
le problème sur
le problème ch ça va repartir ça va
repartir alors si nous sommes dans cette
situation qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
qu'on le regrette au moins il faut
profiter pour faire le maximum pour
prévenir des nouveaux conflits dans
l'avenir et moi je pense qu'il faudrait
faire une grande conférence
internationale pour parler pas
uniquement de la séri mais toutes la
région toutes la région comment essayer
aller vers les ententes des peuples qui
vivent là-bas et vous savez que le droit
international il admet le changement des
frontières si c'est consenti et si c'est
réglé sur le plan alimbiable sur le plan
international et garanti par les Nations
Unies c'est-à-dire les français si vous
prenez toute l'histoire de l'humanité
les frontières changé
souventit grâce aux guerres mais on peut
le faire aussi politiquement il y a il y
a des exemples par exemple
Tchécoslovaquie c'est un cas unique mais
ils se sont séparés c'est un divorce à
l'amiable sans aucun problème et puis il
y a l'autre cas le ygoslavie avec tous
les guerres tout le sang qui a été versé
il y a plusieurs cas de figure la
question de de prochorian c'est une
question à part c'est c'est une autre
civilisation c'est un un branliot très
très très compliqué mais il faut il faut
il faut réfléchir il faut penser mais
avant tout entendre les gens qui
habitent il faudrait les entendre les
écouter quand nous disons on parle de de
de Bachar etassad il faut qu'il parte
nous disons écoutter attention c'est le
peuple syrien qui doit
décéder c'est c'est c'est lui qui doit
décéder et c'est la même chose pour tous
les autres pays de la région c'est eux
qui doivent être à la base de la
décision et notre rôle c'est de garantir
cette décision mais pas imposer c'est là
la différence entre notre approche et
l'approche de l'Amérique veut d'abord
imposer et puis garantir par la force ça
marche pas oui Nicolas mean membre des
du groupe de réflexion les econoclastes
pensez-vous que les deux navires Mistral
auraient pu être utille à la Russie et à
son allié la France pour combattre daesh
en Syrie et quel impact de cet
imbrogliot des navires sur les relations
économiques futures de la France avec la
Russie
don je pense pas je pense pas que les
navires Mestral auraiit pu servir à
l'opération en Syrie puisque ce sont pas
des des navires d'attaque c'est c'est
c'est une très bon c'est son très bon
navir mais pour d'autres choses on
n'attaque pas avec les Mistral pour ça
il y a d'autres d'autres armes alors
mais nous sommes très heureux vraiment
je je vous dire que ces navires ont
finalement été vendu à l'Égypte qui
peut-être en aura besoin àgypte c'est un
pays ami à la Russie avec qui nous avons
une très bonne coopération et d'ailleurs
c'est un miracle je crois que cette
affaire de
Mistral a été réglée avec presque aucune
retombée négative sur nos relations on a
trouvé une solution dans laquelle tout
le monde est resté c'est
content sûrement sûrement pour la
coopération dans le domaine sensible
puisque vous savez que ces dernières
années entre la Russie et la France il a
eu des bons avancés dans la coopération
dans le domaine de l'industrie de la
défense d'ailleurs les deux pays étaient
intéressés bien sûr maintenant ça va ça
va créer quelques frass parce que si on
travaille dans les domaines tellement
sans s il faut avoir la confiance
et l'affaire de Mestral c'était un coup
sévère pour la confiance ça c'est
sûr dernière
question avant dernière alors bonjour
pierrein Lafille ingénieur
conseil ne pensez-vous pas
que un peu plus loin le micro parce
qu'onentend pas ne pensez-vous pas que
les principaux problèmes que rencontrent
les sociétés enfin les les états
occidentaux et notamment la France sont
du fait qu'ils sont entravés par deux
principes le principe de précaution qui
empêche je vous en pas le principe de
précaution le principe de précaution
qui le principe de précaution qui
empêche de faire ce ce qu'il faut et le
principe du politiquement correct qui
empêche de dire ce que l'on pense et
d'autre part au niveau de les limidation
de daesh n'est-ce pas un faux problème
dans la mesure où
euh dans la lutte antiterroristes dans
la mesure où avant daesh il y avait
Al-Qaïda et Al-Qaïda n'avait pas d'état
et ça ne les empêchait pas de faire des
attentat terroriste un petit peu partout
le seul avantage que je vois donc dans
l'élimination de daesh c'est la
possibilité de retour des migrants dans
leur
pays bien
alors rappelez-moi les premières
question mais
brièvement voilà voilà ça c'est très
très important ça c'est très important
vous avez parlé de l'entrave des
entraves je crois que c'est vrai c'est
vrai que ce politiquement correct la
pensée unique nuit énormément à la
France et au d'autres sociétés
occidentaux là encore une fois je peux
faire une comparaison avec l'Union
soviétique c'est à peu près la même
chose c'estàdire c'était aussi un pays
avec la pensée unique la Pravda c'était
le Bible qu'il fallait lire le matin et
vivre avec jusque le soir en France
c'est le monde qu'il faut lire le matin
et dire ce qu'il y a là dedans sinon
vous n'êtes pas entendu ça nuit
terriblement terriblement nous avons
nous avons passé par là et moi je pense
qu'il faut se libérer
de cette pensée unique d'ailleurs je
constate que aujourd'hui en France les
électeurs votent pour les gens qui sont
politiquement
incorrectes voilà parce que les gens
veulent entendre la vérité qu'on parle
des choses vraies qui les
préoccupent par exemple je suis je suis
en tant que chrétien orthodoxe je suis
choqué que aujourd'hui on ne se bat
contre les crèches de
Noël ça je suis nous sont perplexes je
ne sais pas j'ai pas encore vu l'arbre
de Noël devant le NotreDame de Paris
est-ce qu'il en aura parce que l'année
dernière c'est la Russie qui a offert
l'arbre de Noël à Paris et qui était
devant le notterdam il a eu toute une
bagarre autour comment ça je passe mais
on peut pas se se renier on peut pas se
renier c'est vraiment c'est l'esprit
muniois on vous attaque on vous tue et
vous vous et vous dites non non non pour
ne pas les disons antagoniser on va on
fait plus des crèches n'importe quoi je
m'excuse mais comme j'ai vécu longtemps
en France et ça me touche en tant que
chrétien encore une fois et là c'est un
des enseignements je crois que ce qui
s'est passé avec les régionales on voit
ce des enchantement des Français
dans les partis politiques traditionnels
dans le politiquement correct et il faut
tirer des leçons il faut se changer il
faut revenir au temps des lumières mais
il faut pas que ça finit par une
révolution
française et alors la deuxème question
c'était daesh faux problème oui daesh
c'est écoute je suis d'accord avec vous
qu'aujourd'hui c'est hier c'était alkaïa
aujourd'hui c'est daesh demain ce sera
une autre chose qui va avoir une autre
appellation contrôlée mais ça sera la
même chose et la force de daesh la force
des islamistes n'est pas dans les chars
dans les armes leur force est dans les
idées qu'ils propagent qui sont hélas
attractives pour beaucoup de gens et ça
c'est la question qu' doit se poser
pourquoi ces idées sont attractives pour
des gens pourquoi ils sont convertit à
l'islam radical c'est ça le vrai
problème
et là mais c'est ce sont des questions
profondes qu'il faut revoir toute
évolution de la société française et
européenne depuis 30 40
ans on parle de la
léïité moi je j'ai rien contre mais je
crois que la laïcité crée un vide à
l'intérieur des gens mais les jeunes ils
cherchent quelque chose ils ont besoin à
à rêver on peut pas rêver d'aller à
super marcher acheter quelque chose
c'est pas un rêve les société de
consommation ne fait pas rêver il faut
donner quelque de l'espoir de des choses
à quoi on peut rêver et ce sont des faux
rêves que les islamistes offrent à la
jeunesse mais ces faux rêves sont
attractifs c'est ça le vrai problème ça
concerne l'éducation l'enseignement
énormément de choses c'est vraiment
l'occasion pour s'arrêter pour se poser
la question essentielle où où
allons-nous et pourquoi on est arrivé là
et là on trouvera des réponses peut-être
ensemble bon dernière question pour
mettre fin à cet entretien on a pour
habitude de laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations alors donnez un un
conseil pour les jeunes générations sur
Internet écoutez aimez-vous les uns les
autres dans le sens large non moi non
non moi moi je pense que ce qui manque
pas uniquement aux jeunes mais à des
gens de tout âge il faut se voir plus le
plus souvent il faudrait que les jeunes
aillent en Russie découvrir les jeunes
Russes ça leur va ouvrir les yeux ils
vont voir que de l'autre côté de
l'Europe sont leurs amis qui sont qui
n'attend que ça pour leur tenir le bras
la main vraiment il y a très peu de
contact
vous savez euh je je me souviens on a
cette année c'était l'année de 40e
anniversaire de l'acte final d'elsinki
et là il a eu le 3ème fameuse 3è
Corbeil les contacts entre les hommes du
temps de l'Union soviétique on était
farouchement contre parce qu'on savait
très bien que c'est la plus grande force
au monde les contact entre les hommes et
les femmes sans doute et alors et entre
les deux
et ça reste il n'y a rien de plus fort
que les contacts entre les hommes il
faut aller les uns vers les autres et là
on trouvera beaucoup de solutions il y
aura sûrement beaucoup moins de
problèmes c'est le message que je veux
envoyer à des jeunes de France Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur Orlof
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci